Google products provide the information
you need when you need it
but why can't you get the same kind of
answers for your business
looker Google Cloud's business
intelligence solution is here to solve
that problem enabling you to go beyond
traditional dashboards and make your
organization's information accessible
and useful
bringing this Innovation to business
will be revolutionary just like
navigating a city after Google Maps
looker is Google for your business data
here's what we mean what if Google AI
were built into the tools you use to
store and analyze data at work
whose vertex AI Vision takes data like
video images and audio and in real time
turns it into structured data ready for
business intelligence
going beyond the dashboard means using
Google Glass Enterprise to see insights
and recommendations based on your data
in real time more access more
transparency now that's Google for your
business
with Google Maps you know if a
restaurant is busy before you go or you
can get rerouted or out of traffic jam
looker will help you connect similar
dots in a predictive way
a concert in five days will increase
foot traffic by 65 percent would you
like to adjust Staffing and inventory
yes
looker and AI lets you respond to
changes in demand and turn insights into
action
foot traffic continues to be busy
encourage customers to visit an
alternate Shop with a reward card yes
smarter insights mean better experiences
and happy customers
to go beyond the dashboard and transform
the way you do business with looker
powered by Google Cloud